brand new polling on the biden
presidency and some of the major issues
you're talking about by the day
we're also watching two major stories
vice president kamala harris is finally
going to the southern border
the president's point person on the
immigration matter will travel to el
paso on friday
but we begin tonight with president
biden outlining his policy
to address the growing epidemic of
violent crime in america
his focus overwhelmingly and as expected
is
on guns white house correspondent peter
ducey starts us off tonight from the
north lawn there
peter good evening good evening bill and
just a few minutes ago the president
said he never gives up hope
that congress could someday pass an
assault weapons ban
but that in the meantime he thinks there
are more common sense measures that can
be taken
to protect crime ridden cities making
the same
joke twice he doesn't think anybody
needs a gun with a hundred rounds of
ammo
unless they think a deer is wearing
kevlar
we're not changing the constitution
we're enforcing it
the headlines of the president's
multi-point plan are arrest
rogue firearms dealers help former
prisoners re-enter the community
and expand employment opportunities for
young adults they help make sure young
people pick up a paycheck instead of a
pistol but critics argue
criminals are emboldened by softer
sentencing standards and bail reform
the biden five point plan will not
address
the rise in murder and vicious assaults
in this country
we have a lack of prosecution and we've
declared war on the police
and that is backfiring on those who have
done it on another front the vice
president
is ready to make her first trip to the
southern border
the vice president will travel to el
paso texas on friday
that's even though the white house said
two months ago her focus is not
on the border it's on addressing the
root causes
in the northern triangle and even though
the vp herself said two weeks ago
you haven't been to the border i and i
haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't i don't understand
the point that you're making i'm not
discounting the importance of the border
texas lawmakers are
puzzled by the harris itinerary el paso
is on on the western tip of texas the
rio grande
is valley is almost on the southern tip
of texas
it's 800 miles away to give you a sense
of just how far they are
chicago illinois is closer to washington
d.c
than el paso is to mcallen it's unclear
why the vice president is visiting the
border
this week but the announcement comes
just ahead of a trip to the texas-mexico
border by
former president trump was it important
for
the white house to have her seen at the
border before
former president trump has a trip there
next week
we made an assessment within our
government about when it was an
appropriate time for her to go to the
border
and on the same day we find out the vice
president is going to go to the border
we also find out the biden harris
administration sent
a letter to the head of the border
patrol giving him
three options relocate retire
or resign and rodney scott the chief
wrote on his facebook he's going to
stick around 60 more days
in the position and then at that point
the administration will be able to put
in
somebody that they want in the job bill
lot to talk about later thank you peter
ducey from the white house tonight